fairly Europe is among many wrestling
with tough Economic Times
people are grappling with annual
inflation of 64 and unemployment of 10
percent
that's a strain on this coaching
business
a year or two ago we had more students
now it's hard we can't buy mats or
equipment
often governments adjust interest rates
to control inflation
but it's a tricky move raising rates may
bring down prices but it can cause
economic growth to Tumble too
to avoid that the government has kept
rates low prices have remained High and
the economy has become an election issue
some analysts say authorities are right
to prioritize growth so you can't use
the same interest instrument as the US
dollars or european economy is the UK is
using because demand or even factors
their main issue in those advanced
economies authorities in Turkey see
inflation here as a problem of supply
prices are all about supply and demand
as we know and when prices are high one
of the things that governments often try
and do is raise interest rates which has
the impact of taking money out of
society because people have less access
to it and then hopefully prices go down
this government is trying to do
something different though it's trying
to leave interest rates alone leave the
access to money as it is but then
increase production because businesses
now have better access to money too and
with more products in society than
demand hopefully prices go down because
of supply
it's an unorthodox policy and it's yet
to actually lower prices
but it has kept the wheels of the
economy turning with annual growth at
5.6 percent
still turkia Imports more than it
exports leaving a current account
deficit that undermines investor
confidence
some economists say a reckoning is
inevitable
at some point something will have to
give by something I mean either the
interest rate or the exchange rate
if they insist on controlling the
interest rates and the exchange rate
ultimately the exchange rate will
implode
for consumers like Dilbert archetuck
it's not an academic debate I went
shopping with her to see how it's
getting hard to buy the usual
ingredients
I'm asking what are we gonna buy
chocolate no no no I can't put that much
anymore can't you see how expensive
beans are now I'm being told off because
I'm taking too much if Promises of a
better tomorrow don't satisfy people it
may be voters who serve authorities a
disappointing dish
Istanbul
all right let's continue talking about
economics and we're delighted to have
joining us professor of Economics here
Jim chamakla thanks so much for being
with us so first of all is economics
going to be the issue above all that
decides this vote uh certainly certain
the economics is the main issue that is
determining I mean the the outcome of
this elections but this is not the first
time that we had this economic
circumstances I mean in 2001 we had a
deep economical Financial uh
problem this one's a little different
though right
peaked we've got uh well the annual rate
of 60 uh yes yeah it's different because
it's quite long lasting and second uh
like two years ago we didn't have that
high inflation we had just around 10
percent of inflation but just over a
couple of months the inflation just
soared to from values of like 15 to
values like 60 70 and 80 at its peak so
it was so fast such that as you said uh
people really felt the bite in their
wallet very fiercefully right so
previously we didn't have that kind of a
very fast accumulation of increase in
the prices it was quite slow all right
now there's a lot of criticism uh
especially from the opposition towards
the arc party about the economy
inflation unemployment and so on but if
you look at the the annual inflation
rate 64 like I said for 2022 the latest
inflation rate for April came down to 43
yes is the government unorthodox policy
working albeit very slowly uh I don't
think so this is actually a mechanical
reduction in this sense that so last
year is the same month after last year
we had very very high inflation that is
just replaced with high inflation but
lower than the months of the last year
but it's lower even if you go back to
like October we had that peak of 85 it's
if you look at the peak where half right
it's consistently going down but it
seems that that's the new equilibrium of
the new Point uh inflation Point uh in
the sense that probably will be around
like 40 percent uh uh in the coming
months so the thing is inflation is high
compared to what it was like three years
ago all right it's not about the
opposition there's a lot of question
about what the art party
can or has not done what about the
opposition do they have a plan to change
this to tackle this problem of inflation
actually what makes this election so
different is that the two main parties
are cape and opposition group they
really suggest four different economic
policies are completely different model
completely different models our Cape
promises that they will continue with
what they were doing in the last two
years whereas the opposition group they
suggest that they promises that they
promised that they will continue with
more conventionally agreed Orthodox
policies putting up interest rates and
let's face it if you do that all the
economists I know and I've been talking
to you saying there's definitely going
to be a period perhaps of even greater
economic pain because you'll shrink the
economy yes but uh the of course the
interest rates should go up if you
follow more conventional policies but
that will be more like eclectic so first
you shall see the reaction of inflation
then the height interest rate so the
real thing is here the real interest
rates right not to know I'm not the
central bank's policy so if inflation
comes down slowly then you also don't
need to raise the rate so harshly and on
the other hand if you can manage the
expectations if you can manage to have
some inflows to the country then you can
also do the job without raising interest
rate that high so managing expectations
is a key word though isn't it and that's
what both sides have been talking about
and that's perhaps the Achilles heels
for everyone who runs a country right
but thanks so much Jim Jennifer it was
so good talking to you appreciate your
expertise well there you can see it when
it comes to economy what most economists
say is this is not going to be an easy
ride for the country whoever wins going
forward we're approaching the time when
campaigning is going to cut off we're
approaching of course tomorrow's
critical vote that will decide perhaps a
new direction for this country more ways
than one we'll be here covering it
bringing you every development for now
I'm going to hand you back to Doha